what's happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we are here to watch
Brooklyn Nine-Nine season five or
episode nine today John how's it going
uh it's going pretty good how are you
hey man in front of me
I don't know what you're talking about
leave a like leave a goddamn like also
uh full length Reaction watch songs
releasing with your own copy available
for super sexy rejects cover a bunch of
shows exclusively over to patreon thank
you also for sure your support
let's watch something
[Music]
hey there Boyle how was your weekend
well actually I got a little sick oh
really Bullets Over Broadway was on TV I
came down with a big old Diane Wiest
infection
Ace
like yeast
[Music]
that was a pretty exquisite
shared pause did you guys see a black
backpack sitting around anywhere why
what's in the backpack uh just some
evidence do you guys know a drug dealer
named flock
well the bag belongs to one of his
Runners and it contains like a
football's worth of cocaine I'm not good
with sizes hey if you see something say
something oh that is catchy huh it's
like I just made up a hit song not very
common police expression
can't find that evidence he could be
fired
that is catchy what if those drugs end
up on the street
like you're trying to say if it's
whatever because just leave it on
something you're from free of course I'm
pumping fine we'll find the bag come on
a party tonight damn it
we have to reduce energy usage by 15
that means no more laminating Santiago
not the thing that gives me the most
pleasure in life interacting with other
people that's what gets me going
[Laughter]
sard You Beautiful Bastard get rid of
them and Gina you can't run that space
heater 24 7 anymore space heater
this is a foreign ax radiant Comfort
System oh my it's like a toaster he
didn't mean that darling seriously turn
off the space heater heard all this
stuff come from you don't want to start
a battle of the wills with Gina linetti
because you will emerge from that battle
of broken man not to brag but I was name
checked and my kindergarten teacher's
suicide note
[Laughter]
why are you helping this guy sir he's
the opposite of everything you stand for
his favorite expression is that's gonna
leave a mark and he doesn't even use it
right
oh that soup is good that's gonna leave
a mark what but I arrived at it
independently this is security footage
from the day the backpack went missing
11AM the bag's over a cheer now let's
fast forward and see what happened to it
wait that was two hours we're CJ during
all this
[Music]
day tonight the guy's got good hooks I
mean
Flacco must have sent someone to get the
backpack and they just waltzed right in
and took it out of the precinct oh CJ is
in so much trouble
found a 24-hour foot massage parlor and
it's amazing it's the best experience
you've ever had you're just like
foreign
[Laughter]
could never be a Tarantino I told the
brass that I lost a bag and I screwed up
the whole Flacco case and you were wrong
it was a biggie yeah well you told me to
sugarcoat it and whose fault is that
Jake yours I know
they're pulling my transfer do I
transfer what now oh I've just been
feeling overwhelmed with this job I
don't know if you've noticed but I'm a
little in over my head completely
unqualified yeah it is so cool oh my God
they were gonna transfer him already so
I put him for it wait you want to train
other officers well the nine years at
the Academy were some of the best years
of my life that's a six month program
sure for a lot of people
[Laughter]
they're pissed so it looks like I'm
stuck here forever no no no no shame we
are gonna get you the hell out of here
are you sugarcoating this for me I most
certainly I'm not
gonna leave a mark
that it is what's the plans huh well Dad
I think he'd be great Undercover
[Music]
let's roll up on these Muchachos great
start and I love your W's of muchachos
hey it's CJ by the way yeah you know how
I took the lieutenants exam last week I
just found out I didn't pass plus my
bathroom break during the test took a
little longer than anticipated yeah he's
a restroom please
that's why they say it's test time so
diaper up they say that I've never said
that I've never worn a diaper during a
death
[Laughter]
test time so die for a diapers
someone's trying to
diaper up diaper up
get that on the T-shirt no problem what
are we looking for he's a one-armed
Smuggler from the
from the jet goes by the name of Senor
Riff Raff you're taking me to that foot
massage place I am taking you to the
foot massage place I need the whole
thing up shock ing
I'll do it once as long as you promise
to never ever talk about foot milk again
deal You're Gonna Love It I guarantee
you I won't
[Music]
she got big big feet must have a big
penis
definitely I'm terrified but you know I
just keep telling myself worse comes to
worse just start shooting things you
know I think it might be better if you
stay in the band your job will be to
keep an eye on the restaurant and if
anybody's suspicious walks in you just
run everybody over with the van and then
back up if they're still moving
Gina did you shut off your space heater
yet doesn't ring any bells jacinta oh no
she's still going strong I will take
that thing away from you by force if
necessary well coming get it
the heaters under your skirt there's a
cord running under it and I think you
may be on fire you do not have the upper
hand in this situation I always have the
upper hand
not when this flame shooting out of your
butt especially when there's flames
you Severino who wants to know I'm Cal
this is Billy we used to buy from
Rosario but he got busted by the feds
and we're looking for a new hookup guys
we got company this lady with a dog and
a man with a ponytail another lady with
a dog
guys
[Laughter]
can somebody call
was that was that you Jake if it was you
cough twice if it was somebody else
caught three times pollen count is off
the charts
oh man how do you come up with that
stuff so what you doing
quality products
apparently there's such a thing as too
much Smash Mouth I'm sorry
complete strangers
shut up CJ
obviously we're cops put your hands up
whoa who said we were cops we haven't
gotten the information we needed yet
Jake you're blowing it man
[Music]
Crimson investigators come to every inch
of severino's restaurant no drugs well
we can't hold them much longer and he's
not talking the interrogation did not
exactly go well you're gonna tell us who
Flacco is and you're gonna tell us right
uh he's gonna transfer out of the
Nine-Nine he's still trying to undermine
the man what no the opposite of anything
I want to see him succeed I'm trying to
overmine him oh you know I hate it when
you make up
makeup are you still mad at me for
saying snack accident yes very use that
tell me what it was about my speech that
didn't work for you
I had to boil it down to one thing and
really pinpoint it I guess I would just
say it's uh you're boring but still let
him come great he's not boring
you can't tell anyone else this but he
failed his Lieutenant's exam how do you
know that let's just say my little birds
are everywhere collecting Whispers
Gina finger everybody ready where's CJ
parked a block away on Winthrop as
promised don't worry he's not going
anywhere I downloaded an app on his
phone that makes your words sound like
burps really smart
yes that's a lot of drugs
[Music]
that's Flaco you got him yeah he's out
cold how'd you do it no no wait let me
guess
you opened your car door into it yep you
never saw it coming yep and neither did
you it was a total accident you were
getting out of your car to go pee no it
was a spider in the car and I panicked
neither of us have any open cases right
now
so should we tell the ladies we're ready
for round two let's do it you insatiable
little minks I'll go get them
[Music]
um
foreign
money laundering or something we gotta
get out of here right now I just got off
the phone with One Police Plaza they're
thrilled awful you got to transfer I'm
not transferring what why the whole
reason I wanted to transfer in the first
place is because I didn't feel like I
could do this job but the mission
tonight me taking down Flacco more the
door than you just showed me that I can
do this thank you guys for for making me
believe in myself again
that's gonna leave a mark
why are there so many reporters even the
times is here
Wilson Palmer Schneider Levine Rogers
Tyler Baker Coryell bronwidge Robin
Schmidt stop saying reporter's names how
do you know so many names they're the
only real rock stars we have left
[Laughter]
pleasure to bestow upon him the Medal of
Honor Captain Stanley oh
Kitty
cornholio
[Laughter]
why was Flacco targeted for this
operation because I lost a huge bag of
cocaine so I totally biffed it thank you
that was a train wreck yes he never
should have been put in that position
whoever recommended him for the medal
and called all those reporters really
messed up wait what do you saying oh
nothing it just seems as if CJ has been
I hated it over mind
what have I become was this whole thing
even worth it it's not an accident
let's not be Hasty about this let's
think this through we want to be smart
about this right I mean what if we bust
them tonight and then tomorrow I'm
chasing a murderer I'm about to get him
and my foot cramps up due to lack of
massaging
[Laughter]
writing looting panic in the streets I
gotta call the National Guard there's
tanks rolling down Fifth Avenue
declaring martial law it's insane all
because we shut down a foot massage you
cannot do it what were we thinking so
it's agreed we let them stay open for
the sake of the city
sake of the city
we have to do our stupid jobs don't we
yeah let me get my stupid gun
get down on the comfortable minute floor
put your magical hands where you can see
them you're under arrest ruining
something perfect money laundry yes
money on whatever
same difference
Captain Raymond Holt will be taking his
place and yes he's taking all of us with
him you mean yes Amy we're back on the
day [ __ ]
come on and party tonight
that is CJ lives on that is catchy ah
that was a really funny episode what's
his name Ken Marino Ken Marino he sounds
like a baseball player but he's not
okay yeah Kent Marines just sounds like
it does you're right you're right you're
right about that
yeah when camerino's first scene I was
like oh man I don't know why this guy's
still around
he's not that funny
and then he got so funny
yep yeah because I haven't had five of
Cameroon funny in like a bunch of other
things
um but the but and then like like his
character's fine but I was like it was
fine for like the couple episodes he was
into really need more of him here but
there's no age group
I think the way they they uh use this
character here to be a nuisance was
really well done oh yeah I love the
whole bit when they're on the car and
he's so shut up for the earpiece I feel
like they let him just in Bravo [ __ ] ton
of things
really funny because he's he's got that
sincere dumbfound like that sincere dumb
quality like he he plays really straight
and he doesn't play dumb he's not
judging the character whatsoever yeah he
seems like genuinely naive and stupid
and I I love I love the character I
agree to love him and I thought it was
really really entertaining and I just
thought it was a really witty episode it
was witty it was clever you know when
the use of the the reoccurring words of
um uh uh overmine him and accidents an
accident yeah I thought that was really
well done him constantly like coming up
with phrases that have already been
thought of the whole thing with uh you
know Amy's bit about being like a neat
freak like Monica from Friends but her
being like this perfectionist uh
academic driven type of individual that
she had like the winning line for me
with
uh
test time diapers
I'm just thinking across how many
campuses has that happened because it
must be a thing that some people do it's
a funny bit they had a really funny line
it's very funny and then we're just
there you just see it you're just in the
room you know yeah yeah Gina's secretly
caring this was a really fun episode
even like even the foot massage bit it
was kind of whatever to me it it seemed
it wasn't that like funny to me but the
the final moments of it were so
hilarious like when they are tumbling
down why they should have taken and then
when they go to a wrestling this [ __ ]
there's no okay that's just hilarious it
all paid off for that final bit for me
like the actual the the first two bits
of it were not that funny but but that
final moments were were hilarious yeah
it was it was a great it was a great
build up and payoff because I was just I
mean yeah like the the first bits are
not as funny I was you know just
enjoying that catharsis of like man I
should get a foot massage they look so
relaxed but yeah the the turnaround was
like really tight and it made everything
worth it well it's fun when you have
Rosa who's very when she indulges
herself in the Boyle world yeah with it
like takes serious and and it goes along
with similarly hours yeah yeah because
they're like one she's so much more dry
humor um deadpan and so so when she goes
into like buying into the world of The
Whimsy it's really funny so I thought
this was a really funny episode this is
really fun yeah yeah it was a good one
they get their day shift back good for
them yeah I'm gonna miss the knights but
it's about time and two I mean it was a
nice uh you know
I I'm always happy to see various of
these recurring guest stars again but it
did sort of wrap up that like okay we
don't see CJ if we don't see Ken Marino
anymore it makes sense like now there's
a wrap up on that story
it was like funny annoying though oh
yeah I mean it's a thin line it is a
very thin line and two like the way that
scene is edited and then the overlapping
dialogue like it really does transport
you to this sort of like I'm trying to
focus I'm trying to hear what Jake and
Holter saying because they're trying to
focus on what they're saying to keep up
the front and and yeah you just got him
chattering away
um it was great yeah that was great so
yeah guys that's her Delight what did
you guys think of the episode leave your
thoughts down below be sure to subscribe
click that Bell leave a like let's send
this for the
Gene Jeter our last patron of the day
shout out for the month Jean linetti and
I'm pretty sure you take the cake here
yeah you have from you or Andrew Hayes
one of the two but wanted to bookend
this with the highest yeah
I won't say how much you pledge but you
are the highest pledges
undoubtedly
for 50 months 50 months 50 months that's
a very very long time four years and
some change and and and you have not
wavered from being one of the highest
pledges we've had so thank you for the
support do we have a video of shouting
out for Gene this month
uh yes we we did shout out it was um oh
was it a try on haul I want to say at
the beach oh with the hot girl at the
beach with the hot girl at the beach
yeah I think I watched that multiple
times
50 times to increase the the views to
help him out as much as possible because
he's Gene you know
um it's cold out but but transport
yourself to some warm tropical Vibes
with Gene and and uh his Muse here
trying Hall Nelson's clothes beautiful
stuff beautiful stuff
she's dude we should all be so Regal
Queen she is a queen captured by Gene
and on camera not you know physically
don't if you ever want someone to if
you're like feeling sick and you want
someone to like do your filming job one
day I I'd be happy to fill in man sure
just if you really need it I I don't
mind just looking at this I think I can
do a good job I could be professional if
you really just like I imagine it's a
lot of work and you've been a patron of
ours for a while so uh I'd love to help
out if you know you really want that
I'll take something that load up your
films the people the girls if you want
we can direct we can pose them we can
pick out the wardrobes and stuff just
let me know buddy I'll be there I'll
totally buy a plane ticket and be there
for the hours required definitely it
seems like it would be a great way to
pay you back whatever it takes man so
Gene thanks for being part of our page
follow him on Gene Jeter TV yes talk
with y'all soon
[Music]